In lesson 3,
we looked at text field customization.
We created delegate objects which
implemented the protocol that
the UI text field class
was designed to use.
In this lesson,
we're going to look at table views.
And, you'll see that they're more
complex, but that their architected
in a similar way, just like text views,
table views use delegates.
Both view classes need view controllers
to implement delegate protocols,
in order to invoke
the methods they need.
Methods that would be inappropriate
to implement inside of view class.
Again, with tables, you'll see that
we can customize UI kit views by
implementing their protocol
methods in our own way.